Wasser.
Erde.
Feuer.
Luft.
Der Avatar ist der Einzige,
der alle Elemente beherrscht.
Willkommen zum 2. Teil
unserer Doppelfolge
zu "The Last Airbender".
Auch in dieser Folge
haben wir Live-Experimente
für euch vorbereitet.
Mit denen wir zeigen,
wie viel Wissenschaft
in der Serie steckt.
*bedrohliche Musik*
Guten Tag zusammen, Jack Pop hier!
Wie beim letzten Mal nicht alleine,
sondern mit "Avatar"-Experte Fabian.
Hi, Jack.
- Schön, dass du da bist.
Wenn ihr
die 1. grandiose Folge verpasst habt,
schaut sie euch bitte noch an.
Die verlinke ich hier oben.
Da hat uns unsere Physikerin Anne
einführend erklärt,
wie das mit dem Bändigen der Elemente
allgemein funktionieren kann.
Also müssen Bändiger
in der Lage sein,
elektromagnetische Felder
zu beeinflussen.
Damit hätten sie alles,
was sie brauchen,
um Objekte zu bewegen.
Letzte Woche
haben wir Erde und Luft angeschaut.
Heute sind Feuer und Wasser dran.
Lass uns mit Wasser starten.
Dem Element der Veränderung.
*Donner und Trommelmusik*
Wasserbändiger sind die Ersten,
die wir zu sehen bekommen.
Katara hier z.B.
Was können die genau?
Katara kann alles,
was Wasserbändiger können.
Das Wasser hin und her bewegen,
Strudel erzeugen und kämpfen.
Mit Hilfe von Wassersperren
oder Wasserpeitschen.
*bedrohliche Musik*
Gibt es auch
wieder Unter-Bändigungsarten?
Ja, auch die gibt es.
Z.B. im Form vom Pflanzenbändigen
der Sumpfbewohner.
Oder die gruseligste Bändigungsart,
das Blutbändigen.
Indem man sein Opfer
wie eine Marionette kontrolliert.
Okay, das klingt unangenehm.
Wie das funktioniert,
muss uns jetzt Anne erklären.
Wie könnte Wasserbändigen
in der echten Welt aussehen?
Hey, Jack, hey Fabi!
Um Wasserbändigen zu verstehen,
müssen wir uns die Eigenschaften
von Wasser genauer angucken.
Wasser ist elektrisch leitfähig.
Deswegen bei Gewitter nicht ins Bad
und nie den Fön in die Badewanne.
Aber Wasser
mit Strom in Berührung zu bringen,
führt nicht dazu,
dass es sich bewegt.
Wasserbändiger
müssen Magnetismus nutzen.
Wenn ihr jetzt denkt,
dass Wasser kein Metall ist,
dann habt ihr recht,
aber Wasser ist diamagnetisch.
Es baut ein inneres Magnetfeld auf,
was sich einem äußeren
immer entgegensetzt.
Wasser wird von einem Magnetfeld
immer abgestoßen.
Das kann ich euch
mit einem Experiment zeigen.
In der Spritze ist Wasser,
und die hängt an einer Vorrichtung,
damit sie sich frei drehen kann.
Und wenn ich jetzt
mit meinem Magneten hier rankomme,
dann dreht sich
die Spritze vom Magneten weg.
Wasserbändiger
können das genauso machen.
Sie können ein Magnetfeld schaffen
und damit Wasser bewegen.
Funktioniert auch
mit einem elektrischen Feld.
Wasser hat
noch eine interessante Eigenschaft.
Wassermoleküle sind neutral,
aber die Ladung
ist nicht gleichmäßig verteilt.
Das Wassermolekül ist ein "Dipol".
Die eine Seite ist positiv
und die andere negativ geladen.
Das können die Wasserbändiger
sich zunutze machen,
sich selbst elektrisch aufladen
und dann das Wasser bewegen.
Und genau das können wir
euch hier live zeigen.
Willkommen zurück
im Experimente-Setting.
Was machen wir?
- Du sollst gleich Wasser bändigen.
Dafür haben wir
dieses Monstergerät organisiert.
Das ist ein Van der Graaf Generator,
mit dem wir gleich
krasse Ladungen erzeugen werden.
Wenn ihr euch jetzt fragt,
warum ich auf einmal so groß bin:
Ich stehe auf einem Hocker.
Damit ich einmal diese Größe erfahre.
Weil Fabi auch auf dem Hocker steht.
Bei dir ergibt es aber Sinn.
Der soll dich isolieren.
Damit die Ladung nicht
über den Boden abtransportiert wird.
Du stehst erhöht
aus einem guten Grund.
Und dann haben wir das Gerät,
das du gleich berühren darfst.
Es sieht gefährlicher aus
als letztes Mal.
Ja, in der letzten Folge
waren wir bei Spannungen
von ein paar 10.000 Volt.
Jetzt ...
... sind wir
bei ein paar 100.000 Volt.
Hast du immer noch Bock?
- Hey, ich bin bereit, Mann.
Und weil wir im Bereich
von so hohen Spannungen sind,
machen wir das
professionell begleitet.
Matthias ist wieder mit dabei.
Vielen Dank.
Es funktioniert so,
dass da ein Band durchläuft.
Und durch die Reibung,
die dieses Band erzeugt,
haben wir oben an der Kuppel
die krassen Ladungen.
Jeder, der im Winter
einen Wollpulli ausgezogen hat
und bei dem
die Haare geknistert haben,
hat denselben Effekt
von Reibungselektrizität gespürt.
Bei uns ein bisschen krasser.
- Ein bisschen.
*spannende Musik*
Damit man das gut sieht,
habe ich einen schwarzen Hintergrund.
Dann können wir den Bändigungs-Move
ein bisschen besser einfangen.
Fabi, fass mal ran an das Gerät da.
Jawohl.
- Matthias macht das Gerät an.
Ich drehe auf.
Und dann let's go, Wasserbändiger.
Ich bin bereit zum Bändigen.
Guck mal!
Es klappt tatsächlich.
Boah, krass auch, wie weit!
Ah!
Krass!
- Ein richtiger Strahl, ja.
Boah!
Nice!
Okay, da würde ich sagen:
perfekt.
Experiment funktioniert 1A.
- Ich kann Wasser bändigen.
*fröhliche Musik*
Okay, nach dem Prinzip
würde sich so etwas
wie Pflanzenbändigen erklären.
Pflanzen bestehen v.a. aus Wasser.
Das wäre dasselbe Prinzip.
Und Blutbändigen beim Menschen.
Ja, stimmt, und wir wissen auch:
Ist das Blut nicht richtig verteilt,
können wir in Ohnmacht fallen.
*Menschen stöhnen.*
*spannende Musik*
*Sie stöhnen.*
Oh, Shit.
Blutbändigen ist super gruselig.
Aber in der Erklärung
doch relativ simpel.
Ja, aber Wasserbändiger
können nicht nur mit Wasser kämpfen,
sondern auch
Nebel oder Eis bändigen,
was schwieriger ist.
Hm, okay.
Aber Nebel bändigen
können wir hier genauso gut,
wenn du Bock hast.
Fabi, möchtest du
auch noch Nebel bändigen?
Ich bin sowas von bereit.
Okay, dann brauchen wir Nebel.
Wir haben tragbaren Nebel dabei.
Sehr gut, den stellen wir hier hin.
Dann machen wir jetzt das Gleiche,
was wir gerade eben gemacht haben.
Du fasst noch mal an.
Matthias schaltet den Generator an.
Nebel bändigen?
- Let's do it.
Oh ja.
Woah, krass.
Es tut sich was.
- Hey, guck mal.
*spannende Musik*
Aber richtig!
Boah!
- Ja, Mann!
Hey, wie du das rausdrängst.
Mega!
Sieht heftig aus, ja.
- Hahaha!
Hey, Fabi.
Du bist nicht nur Wasserbändiger,
du bist auch Nebelbändiger.
Vielen Dank.
- Sehr gut.
Welches Element würdet ihr
am liebsten bändigen können?
Schreibt es in die Kommentare.
*Donner und Trommelmusik*
Zum Schluss
lass uns auf die Bändiger schauen,
die am Anfang der Story
als die Bösen rüberkommen:
die Feuerbändiger.
Feuer ist das Element der Macht.
Feuerbändiger sind in der Lage,
Feuer zu erschaffen,
zu schießen und zu spucken.
Was nicht nur beeindruckend,
sondern effektiv bei Feinden ist.
Auf jeden Fall.
Das glaube ich dir sofort.
Die können nicht nur Flammen
erschaffen und damit schießen,
sondern ohne Feuer Dinge heiß machen.
Ja, das stimmt.
Anne, lass uns damit anfangen.
Wie könnte das funktionieren?
Wenn wir dabei bleiben,
dass Bändiger elektrische Felder
aufbauen und kontrollieren können,
dann ist das mit dem Feuer
aus dem Nichts leicht erklärt.
Denn wenn Strom fließt,
ist da ein elektrischer Widerstand.
Das bedeutet:
Das Objekt wird warm.
Je nach Höhe des Stroms
kann es sich sogar entzünden.
Ich kann euch das zeigen
mit Batterie und Kaugummipapier.
Wenn ich das Papier
zwischen die Batteriepole spanne,
dann wird es so warm,
dass es in der Mitte anfängt,
zu kokeln.
Die Feuerbändiger
haben nicht ständig Papier dabei,
um Feuer zu entfachen.
Sie machen das
irgendwie in der Luft.
Da gibt es einen theoretischen Weg,
wie das klappen könnte.
Und zwar in 2 Schritten.
Im 1. Schritt
müssen sie dem Kohlendioxid
und dem Wasserdampf in der Luft
mit einem starken elektrischen Feld
Elektronen klauen.
Sie also ionisieren.
Dabei entstehen
positive Ionen und freie Elektronen.
Im 2. Schritt müssen Feuerbändiger
die Ionen mit den freien Elektronen
neu zusammensetzen.
Das nennt man "rekombinieren".
Das ist der umgekehrte Prozess
zum Ionisieren.
Dabei würde Methangas
als Brennstoff entstehen.
Und Sauerstoff,
der die Verbrennung am Laufen hält.
Das Beste ist:
Durch den Zusammenprall
der Ionen mit den Elektronen
haben die Methanmoleküle
so viel Bewegungsenergie,
dass sie sich entzünden können.
Dann verbrennt das Methan
und zerfällt in Wasser und CO2.
Aber noch mal:
Das ist rein theoretisch.
Das Feuer zu kontrollieren,
funktioniert,
weil Flammen ein Teilplasma sind.
Bestimmte Atome sind ionisiert,
und die können beeinflusst werden.
Auch das können wir euch zeigen.
Fabi, wer darf es machen?
Ich, oder?
- Ja.
Das Wichtigste ist:
Wir haben hier offenes Feuer.
Deswegen "safety first".
Der Feuerlöscher ist dabei.
Und wenn du bereit bist, ...
... dann zeig, was du drauf hast.
- Ich bin sowas von bereit.
*spannende Musik*
Hey, auf jeden Fall.
- Ja, die bewegt sich.
Megagut!
Guck mal, die haut richtig ab.
Ist es heiß?
Nein, es geht.
Es geht.
- Guck mal, die haut richtig ab.
Sehr gut.
Aber okay, aufpassen.
Sehr gut!
*Es donnert.*
Also auch hier dasselbe Prinzip:
Wenn wir
ein starkes elektrisches Feld haben,
können Feuerbändiger
so eine Flamme kontrollieren.
Wenn sie es schaffen,
das aus der Luft zu erzeugen,
könnten die das
in alle Richtungen bewegen.
Ja, es klingt auf jeden Fall so,
als hätten Feuerbändiger
viel gleichzeitig zu tun.
Es gibt auch "Sub-Bändigungsarten".
Ah, Unterarten.
Was gibt es da noch?
Feuerbändiger können
durch Fingerspitzen Blitze erzeugen.
Die sie auf ein Ziel feuern
oder durch ihren Körper umleiten.
Dann gibt es noch Brandbändiger,
die können mit ihrem Stirntattoo
Laser irgendwohin schießen.
Der geht dann in die Luft.
Okay, Laser aus der Stirn?
Ich weiß nicht,
ob uns Anne das erklären kann.
Aber das mit den Blitzen
klingt schon plausibler.
Das geben wir mal zurück an Anne.
Blitze erzeugen,
die bewegen und hin und her leiten:
Geht das?
Naja, Blitze sind
nichts anderes als Elektronen,
die sich schnell
durch die Luft bewegen.
Also Strom.
Und unsere Prämisse ist ja,
dass Bändiger Strom erzeugen
und kontrollieren können.
Deswegen sollten
Blitze kein Ding sein.
Um einen Blitz zu erzeugen,
muss man
"nur" genug Spannung aufbauen,
um den Luftwiderstand zu überwinden
und die Luft zu ionisieren.
Dafür brauchen wir
ca. 10.000 Volt pro Zentimeter Luft.
Die Feuerbändiger können eine
energiesparendere Variante nutzen.
Sie können ihren Blitz
statt durch die Luft
durch eine Flamme schicken.
Denn wie wir gesagt haben,
ist Feuer ein Teilplasma,
also teilionisiert.
Der Widerstand
ist da geringer als in der Luft.
Okay, Blitze sind
anscheinend kein Problem.
Wir machen es einfach nach,
und zwar mit diesem Gerät.
Kann ich trotzdem fragen,
warum hier "Lebensgefahr" steht?
Ähm, ja, ich muss dir was beichten.
Bislang haben wir
nur mit hohen Spannungen hantiert
und geringen Stromstärken.
Bei dem Gerät haben wir beides:
hohe Spannung, hohe Stromstärke.
Deswegen müssen wir zurücktreten.
Das wird jetzt
nur von Matthias bedient,
weil das nicht ungefährlich ist.
Lassen wir mal zwischen den 2 Kugeln
einen ordentlichen Blitz entstehen.
Lass uns mal.
- Ich bin gespannt.
Es knistert schon.
- Hm.
Haha, du ahnst Schlimmes.
*lautes Knistern*
*Sie lachen.*
Okay.
Easy.
Lass uns probieren,
was Anne erzählt hat.
Nämlich das mit dem Feuer.
Dass wir den Blitz
durch die Flamme umleiten?
Genau.
Ich stelle
die Kerze jetzt mal hierhin.
Im Idealfall nimmt der Blitz
jetzt den Weg über die Flamme.
*spannende Musik*
*lautes Knistern*
Alter, krass.
Mega, oder?
Wahnsinn.
- Geil!
Krass, hat funktioniert.
V.a., dass wir so viel
wissenschaftlich klären konnten.
Ja, nicht?
Sagen wir, zumindest theoretisch.
Das sind ja hier technische Geräte.
Die Bändiger müssen das biologisch
aus sich selbst hinkriegen.
Das ist wahrscheinlich
schon eher unrealistisch.
Und sie haben noch ein Problem:
Hohe Spannung
ist nicht gleich hohe Energiemenge.
Ich habe hier noch
einen elektrischen Grillanzünder.
Den kann man betreiben
mit einer einfachen Batterie.
Also relativ geringe Energiemenge,
die da vorhanden ist.
Damit können wir hohe Spannungen
von 13.000 Volt erzeugen.
Du nimmst das eine, ich das andere.
*leises Knistern*
Es funkt.
Gewaltig.
Ja, aber der Energiebetrag
ist sehr gering.
Und das ist ein Problem,
das wir schon
in der "Magneto"-Folge hatten.
Der Energie-Erhaltungs-Satz
kommt Bändigern in die Quere.
Denn wenn die einen Stein von 50 kg
hochheben wollen
mit ihren magnetischen Feldern,
dann müssten sie auch dazu
aus Muskelkraft in der Lage sein.
Weil es derselbe Energiebetrag ist.
Wenn die keine Batterien
oder zusätzliche Energie haben,
wird es für die schwierig.
Theoretisch haben sie eine Quelle
in Form von spiritueller Energie.
Das würde funktionieren.
Wenn sie eine Art spirituelle Energie
abgreifen können,
haut das hin,
aber sie haben noch ein Problem:
Dann müsste jeder einzelne Bändiger
ein Avatar sein.
Wenn man einmal
den Elektromagnetismus beherrscht,
kann man
alle Elemente gleich bändigen.
Fabi, wir können festhalten:
Einen wissenschaftlichen Ansatz
haben wir gefunden.
Aber am Ende
hapert es dann doch an der Umsetzung
und an den krassen Energiemengen,
die man dafür braucht.
Ja, aber wir haben
extrem viel gelernt.
Und "Magic that makes sense"
klingt auch cool.
Ja.
Für die Serie,
da bin ich bei dir, passt das gut.
Danke, dass du da warst
und dein Wissen präsentiert hast.
Ich habe zu danken.
Voll gern.
Flitzt ihr mal rüber zu Fabis Kanal,
lasst ein bisschen Liebe da.
Und wo wir bei Liebe sind:
Wir wollen noch Anne danken
für die physikalischen Details.
Danke auch an "Experimente-Shows",
ohne die wir hier
nicht so krasse Blitze gehabt hätten.
Das fand ich sehr cool.
Wenn es euch gefallen hat,
freue ich mich besonders,
wenn ihr einen Kommentar da lasst
einen Daumen nach oben gebt.
Und nicht vergesst, diesen Kanal ...
... zu abonnieren.
Und ...
... die Glocke zu aktivieren.
Dann sehen wir uns wieder, tschüss!
- Ciao!
Tschüss!
Wenn ihr den 1. Teil verpasst habt,
klickt hier oben.
Da seht ihr Erde und Luft.
Wenn ihr mehr von Fabi sehen wollt,
findet ihr da den Kanal zum Bändigen.
Copyright MDR 2022